really when you think about it three
things guide our movements through the
world time space and money time is how
long it takes to get someplace space is
how far away that thing is and whether
you can do it in money is whether you
can afford how much it costs you roughly
to get to that place I was reminded to
this the other day when I took a cab
ride in New York and got what was a
graduate-level lecture in space time and
really in the spatio-temporal aspects of
urban theory the cab driver was talking
about a primarily a really radical
change that's happened on the new york
city streets in the last few years
manhattan you probably know this is a
grid north south avenues east-west
streets and the transportation director
in New York woman named Janette
sadik-khan has built among other things
these really interesting bike paths
they're right next to the curb and the
parking is outboard of them in the
street and then there are sort of
plantings and painted lanes in the
streets to make sure people know where
they're supposed to park know what's
supposed to ride their bike but the
cabbie said here's what's changed used
to me that if you were going to try to
make let's say a left turn you would be
in the leftmost lane trying to make that
turn and you could kind of sneak into a
left turn from the lane right next to
that so there were two lanes that were
able to make that turn now one of those
lanes is gone you're in that outboard
lane and there are in a lot of streets
traffic signals that guide when you can
make that turn and they let people cross
before you can go so you have to wait
for whatever pedestrians are there so
that means that now there's only one
lane and instead of two cars from Elaine
that would have been able to sneak
through now only one can used to be four
cars from a street right now it's just
the one that means that all those other
cars that were trying to turn have to
wait for their turn and all the cars
behind them back up some of the new
lanes for example are sometimes only
supposed to be for buses but it's
different times of day in different days
you have to keep that in mind or you get
a ticket that means that sometimes
they're full of a bus sometimes they're
not Plus different streets have trucks
on them at different times of day and
different days of the week because
they're delivering goods to the stores
on those streets assuming their streets
with the street level retail what all
that means in the aggregate is that a
cabbie has to not only have a spatial
map in his or her head of the city but
another dimension a temporal map as well
because the city changes over time
at different times a day it's a
different city not gonna be thinking I
started to be some reading on this and
of course urban theorists and planners
have been trying to figure this out for
a long time sorry but it's a hard
problem cities are different at
different times of day in different
places as an example a downtown a place
where a lot of people come into work is
incredibly diverse during the day
socioeconomically racially because there
are a lot of people there with different
specialties from different places but at
the end of the day over the evening it's
really homogenous and that's going to be
true in a neighborhood too because
neighborhoods residential neighborhoods
tend to be pretty homogeneous
socioeconomically and ethnically how do
you plan for that kind of stuff yeah I
don't really know planners tend to think
of the where and not the win so could
you build a city that was that was ready
to be different at a different time yeah
maybe I mean maybe that's about lighting
or you know for nighttime use I know
that when you look at maps of where New
York taxi cabs do pickups and drop-offs
you can see different places in the city
light up with heat you know it's late in
the afternoon it's mid town in New York
and Friday and Saturday night it's the
Lower East Side the cabbie was
interesting about this he pointed out
that on his dashboard was a computer and
that you could actually change how much
a fee was to do congestion pricing if
you didn't want people riding around at
certain times a day or he would
appreciate a multiplier to add a couple
of cents per mile on shorter trips to
account for the gas prices right I'm not
sure his writers would appreciate that
as much either well obviously I wanted
to know a lot more about this but
unfortunately we were near the end of
the ride we'd reached our destination
and I'd run out of time
you